i'm going to talk about the non-lesser
car expressions for a minute
that why there are so many uh at the
beginning of the speech
i gave sort of a scenario about how
the attempt to synchronize the
individual sounds may have actually
resulted
in music and group singing but the
purpose of these known laser cut
vocalizations
do a bit more than i mentioned earlier
among other things
these functions they buy time while they
the workers think about new songs to
raise so in that sense these are gap
fillers
they are some kind of comic relief in
the way
that they are uttered and they are
vocalized
they help to provide a steady tempo
encouraging group participation
here is another example of songs
basically highlighting
the use of the non-non-lethical
vocalizations as i mentioned
and how they provide the reference
points for coordinated activity
so actually if you analyze the songs you
will realize that
all these non-lethal vocalizations are
those ones that occur at first intervals
and it is actually these ones that
establish the pulse
in the music and that helps to provide a
reference point for the coordinated
activity
the parts that um let's call where they
overlap and the calls
they overlap and they are actually not
in line with the tempo of the work
itself
so the non-laser cut vocalizations are
short repetitive
and they keep the pulse of the work
going
and they provide a steady tempo
you